>> Marc: HERE
GREAT TO SEE RYAN MURRAY BACK IN
THE  A LOOK AT IT RIGHT EEMS TO
DEADLINE.
>> Marc: POINTS IN ANY
MONTH IN NHL HISTORY.
THE AVALANCHE TRYING TO GET SOM
GOING HERE, MOSE.
>> THE DEFENSEMAN
TAKING TO THE NET.
GETS THE SHOT HE
PUTS TOGETHER.
>> Marc: HE LIKE IT CAUGHT HIMU.
MIDAIR.
>> Peter: KADRI HAD
GOOD PLAY THERE BY THE A ROOKIE
THAT FOR THE PLAYOFFS.
>> Marc: TO THE FRONT OF THELAN.
THE AVS GETTING IN THE KALE.
COULD LITTLE BIT TOO HOT.GALCHE.
THAT IS A PRETHERE COMES THE AV.
BURAKOVSKY LOOKING FOR  GAME  S.
MIKKO
>> Mark: WATCH THE GIRARD.
CAN'T GET IT OUT.
AVS KICSO PUCK OFF.
>> Marc:
THERE IS.
FINALLY ROLLS FREE
WALKING IT, SHOOTING IT.
SAVED BY OTHER TEAM PULLS
THREE-ON-THREE.
THE AVS HAVE BEEN HOT.
>> Marc: THEKOG BACK AGAIN.
THE CAPTAIN WANTS TO LEAD IT
REFS CANNOT CALL.PLAY.
>> Marc: HERE COMES MIKKO.S THEP
HE IS TWO FOR THREREST.
OH, MAN, THE AVS ARE COMES CLAY
KELLER.
THE STREAK IS ON